welcome to this video playing for phony
Bo phony yeah okay the flag game I have
no idea hong kong SAR china okay what is
the SAR stand for no idea okay so we
have have something that I usually call
the Neo Philidor in Maya opening in the
video title it's a fitted or setup
reached by d6 Knight f6 and in this
particular line white can play G for
which I did it's debatable if this is
such a great line but it's it's an
interesting way to use the smooth water
to to get something get something unique
ok yeah I understand but if I have what
about five just breaking through here
yeah this would be the way to to punish
really wow he's a lolly 6am
this looks quite dangerous so just e6 or
is there a better move to 36 what's the
idea all along maybe you should have
flicked and Bishop edge form maybe
Jackie I need to take you anyway so tell
maybe this isn't isn't that terrible for
black how do I play here cannot castle
fraud maybe maybe something like that if
he goes Bishop h4 Bishop g3 I can be
captured Jack queen now can we capture
with the Queen if I like to at least I
can also take with the night and I
prepare long castle this is the most
important thing of course check
this chicken special is 6mm or just long
castle
somehow this feels like it's it's
terribly wrong maybe this one
hmm
I don't know probably that's more than
one good move and i cannot i don't i'm
not able to calculate a win here so
let's guess a long
let them get all pieces involved okay if
I take no I know I can go here
threatening Bishop g6 and if it takes g3
I take with check here this looks very
shaky now also Queen III check prevented
so let's let's check i can also check
here check so good page 4 in g51
blundering g-form this is unnecessary
you can just take g4 ah yeah unnecessary
is putting it mildly it's just as if
developing this bloody piece for him
what the heck
Andrew create now son ah great just
great
so let's let's see
yeah h4 what a move em probably
everything with not blundering something
is just winning because this is just to
take completely completely tied up here
and now I'm just fishing here two points
down yeah it still still some
compensation I can give the check in and
of course this defines Kevin G file so
the only hope really
covering you for and still hoping for
the g4i it's not easy to play
checking f6 and detecting g6
hmm
and it's probably probably not so bad
for white at least it's difficult
yeah Knight f6 still quite a substantial
threat
check
okay so winning again we have one f7f of
the Sun would be would be there dear
maybe I shouldn't shouldn't have allowed
an end game I mean this winning but
check maybe a play for an attack was
easier
check
just need to return to Devon and then
push the a poem
hmm not sure would like forfeits due to
disconnection ROK disconnection hmm yeah
that was just a bad game age for how
would you ought to get that I mean this
is like completely over I can just take
him oh wow what a how long I can just
stay here if you recaptures queen age
seven is pretty good the album came
deserves the turn this is also win check
just plus three all along but this is
just utterly ridiculous I completely
overlooked the g4 hangs it develops a
piece for him and allows roop d8 so f
just terrible the Iron Age 5 i'm
just-just fishing here my queen c4 was
better here in fact yeah
the computer wants to play this year in
five green before Bishop p6 wow yeah
that seems ok you can you can do that
well okay this is just check trying to
complicate matters here here H fibers
it's the the easiest win see if I take
take cm yeah I've lost their no no
question but the way it it was played I
had to add some play this is just giving
it away I thought king of seven and I
wasn't sure how to continue it still
feels like it's a bit tricky but kill me
then I have no no adequate compensation
and this was just gives away the whole
whole game hey Bishop g5 is even
stronger what about a game ok but it's a
win what what can you do look you one
also no better than rook f1 but what
just forget about that thanks for
watching